[Musique]
salut vous avez peut-être cliquer sur
cette vidéo à cause de son titre
légèrement click pate mais quel est
votre profil je vois trois grandes
options
1 vous êtes abonné à ma chaîne et vous
aimez bien ce que je propose vous avez
donc un a priori plutôt positif vous
vous demandez ce que je veux bien
pouvoir raconter pour défendre
l'astrologie 2 vous n'êtes pas abonné à
ma chaîne vous êtes plutôt prêt à croire
à l'astrologie et vous espérez trouver
dans ma vidéo des arguments pour la
défendre face aux nombreuses attaques
venues des sceptiques 3 vous n'êtes pas
abonné à ma chaîne vous vous
reconnaissez dans les scepticisme ou la
zététique et vous vous demandez quel
tissu d'absurdité j'ai bien pu imaginer
pour défendre l'astrologie
alors je crois que le plus simple c'est
de commencer par préciser l'enjeu de
cette vidéo et donc de justifier ce
titre légèrement racoleur
je ne vais pas vous proposer une plongée
rigoureuse au cœur de l'astrologique
comme pour en révéler des dimensions
inconnues du grand public et par la
défendre une nouvelle validité près du
Mansion scientifique on sait que
l'astrologie est une cible
préférentielle pour les sceptiques comme
tout ce qui est lié de près ou de loin
au niveau Edge je ne vais pas attaquer
les contenus sceptiques qui se sont
attachés à débloquer l'astrologie je
sais que Christophe Michel de la chaîne
hygiène mentale s'y attelé je sais que
Serge Bret Morel on a fait le coeur de
son activité sceptique il est donc
important de préciser d'emblée que 1 je
reconnais la validité des critiques en
fait je vais parler très peu
d'astrologie en un sens on peut dire que
cette vidéo concerne tout le temps le
tarot ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
questionner la relation qu'on a à ce
type de discours parce que le thème
astral comme le tirage de cartes sont
des discours des formes de parole
magique censées nous révéler quelque
chose
et je me demande si les critiques qu'on
formule à l'égard de ces discours ne
manquent pas malgré leur validité
formelle une certaine dimension s'il n'y
a pas une autre manière de voir
l'astrologie le tarot etc
deuxième chose à préciser je reconnais
la dangerosité potentielle des pratiques
susceptibles de générer ce qu'on
pourrait appeler l'effet gourou ici par
effet gourou je veux parler de situation
spécifique ou un individu jouit d'une
position dominante du fait qu'on lui
attribue une espèce de supériorité
indéniable parfois quasi surnaturel il
devient alors très facile pour cet
individu de profiter de cette position
et de manipuler celles et ceux qui lui
font confiance aveuglément
mais il me tient vraiment à cœur de
préciser tout de suite je déteste parler
de gourou pour désigner ses individus
c'est à dire au fond dans un contexte
occidental le concept de gourou dans les
spiritualités indiennes et d'une grande
complexité d'ailleurs il ne désigne pas
nécessairement une personne je trouve
insultant de récupérer ce terme pour les
réduire à une insulte signifiant peu ou
pro leader de secte pratiquant
l'endoctrinement et parler d'effets
marabout pour désigner des situations où
quelqu'un profite de la crédulité d'une
personne pour le manipuler à son
avantage soulève exactement la même
problème relativement aux cultures
musulmane africaine
comment faudrait-il appeler ça si vous
avez des idées n'hésitez pas à les
partager en commentaire bref tout ça
pour dire que oui il y a sûrement un
danger potentiel lié à l'astrologie
analogue à celui qui incarne les médiums
et je ne veux pas nier danger la
question que je pose ici est plus large
quel rapport à la croyance le rejet de
ces pratiques révèle-t-il ne critique ne
passent-elles pas à côté de quelque
chose l'approche sceptique était de la
plus pertinente mais elle pas réductrice
bref vous l'avez compris c'est
l'hypothèse que je vais défendre ici et
j'irai même jusqu'à dire que cette
approche cette manière de critiquer ces
pratiques incarne un potentiel danger
pour la pensée c'est ce que je veux
partager avec vous aujourd'hui parce que
c'est bien là la raison d'être de cette
chaîne je ne prétends éduquer personne
je ne suis expert en rien et ne fait pas
en ce sens de vulgarisation je suis
d'ailleurs admiratif de celles et ceux
qui sur Twitter ou sur Youtube rendent
accessible des contenus complexes pour
une audience à vide de nourriture
intellectuelle
celles et ceux qui permettent une
éducation populaire en somme je n'ai pas
les moyens de proposer un tel type de
contenu ce n'est pas comme ça que cette
chaîne fonctionne tout ce que je propose
ce sont des idées des réflexions des
cheminements et vous seuls savez si ce
contenu vous intéresse
un objectif de cette chaîne c'est de
montrer qu'il y a toujours une autre
manière de voir les choses j'ai envie de
nourrir notre capacité à imaginer qu'il
existe une autre perspective une autre
façon de comprendre le monde on pourrait
dire qu'il s'agit de générer de
l'humidité épistémique bref où est-ce
que je vais en venir avec l'astrologie
le tarot et compagnie
je veux dire que notre relation assez
pratique et révélatrice d'un certain
rapport à la croyance et à la
connaissance je vois beaucoup de
similitudes entre celui qui croit et
celle qui ne croient pas au fond même si
les conclusions sont contraires leur
disposition d'esprit ont beaucoup moins
commun
c'est ce que je voudrais montrer en
premier lieu
[Musique]
il faut commencer par poser la question
plus générale de la croyance qu'est-ce
que croire il semblerait selon la
définition intuitive la plus communément
partagée que croire c'est en gros tenir
pour vrai si je crois qu'il y a un stylo
dans mon tiroir c'est que je tiens pour
vrai qu'il y a un stylo dans mon tiroir
mais on peut essayer de présenter le
phénomène mental de la croyance un tout
petit peu plus précisément par exemple
on peut envisager la croyance comme une
représentation c'est à dire tout
simplement que toute croyance accompagne
une sorte d'image mentale qui correspond
à la proposition à la phrase de la
croyance en l'occurrence pour reprendre
le même exemple cela veut dire que
j'aurai dans ma tête une image du stylo
dans le tiroir c'est la position qu'on
appelle représentationnaliste
mais il y a aussi le dispositionnalisme
pour cette posture philosophique ce qui
est essentiel le fait de croire c'est
d'adopter un comportement qui correspond
à la croyance
ce qui fait que je crois qu'il y a un
stylo dans le tiroir ce n'est pas que
j'ai une image du stylo dans le tiroir
dans mon esprit c'est que j'ouvre le
tiroir pour y prendre le stylo l'exemple
qu'on trouve dans l'encyclopédiste Ford
est éclairant imaginons un
extraterrestre qui atterrit en France et
intègre normalement la société il paye
ses impôts militent dans des
associations et fans de rugby même si on
ne se rien de ce qui se passe dans sa
tête il paraîtrait normal de considérer
que cet extraterrestre croit qu'il doit
faire sa déclaration d'impôt en mai et
il croit qu'elle ne s'est transformé en
7 points aucunement besoin de projeter
un contenu mental similaire à celui des
humains imaginons que l'extraterrestre
regarde un match France - Afrique du Sud
l'équipe de France émet de 6 points et
dans les derniers minutes marque un
essai elle transforme l'extraterrestre
alors bondit de joie son comportement
nous permet de déduire qu'il croit comme
le reste des supporters que l'équipe de
France est passé devant et va gagner le
match son comportement révèle sa
croyance
cette première distinction est
intéressante à mes yeux pour au moins
une raison si on s'en tient à l'approche
représentationaliste on peut croire
qu'on croit quelque chose parce qu'on a
une représentation mentale de cette
croyance
l'approche dispositionnaliste peut
révéler une croyance contrairement parce
que notre comportement contredit l'image
qu'on a en tête ces fréquent pour ce qui
est de la politique Bob croissant qu'il
n'est pas raciste parce que quand il
fait une introspection il ne trouve rien
dans son contenu mental qui s'apparente
au racisme à ce qu'il imagine
correspondre à être raciste voire même
il se pense contre le racisme tandis
qu'on peut déceler dans son comportement
une expression de condescendance le
paternalisme ou toute attitude qui
révèle en creux une tendance au cliché à
la généralisation voir tout simplement
une conception inégale des cultures et
donc une forme de racisme
j'aime l'idée que ce que l'on fait
davantage que ce que l'on pense révèle
ce que l'on croit
pour les visuels de la vidéo je prends
des bulles parce que c'est plus pratique
alors il me faut préciser j'aime l'idée
que ce que l'on fait davantage que ce
que l'on dit révèle ce que l'on croit
j'avais déjà un peu abordé cette
distinction dans la vidéo sur la liberté
je voulais faire une différence entre
croyance consciente ou croyance de
surface à laquelle on a accès
immédiatement quand on sonne son esprit
et croyance profonde inconsciente qui
détermine notre manière de vivre plus ou
moins explicitement
bref revenons notre point de départ
l'idée que croire c'est tenir pour vrai
déjà ça pose un énorme problème parce
que ça suppose de savoir ce qu'on veut
dire quand on dit de quelque chose que
c'est vrai et là on est bien obligé de
reconnaître qu'on est un peu dans la
merde si on veut se mettre d'accord sur
ce qui définit la vérité on distingue
plusieurs conceptions de la vérité et
cela mériterait une vidéo à part entière
mais afin d'avancer dans notre réflexion
gardons un esprit simplement ceci 1 la
vérité est une valeur sauf qu'à
particulier nous partons du principe que
le vrai vaut mieux que le faux
2 le fait de croire est étroitement lié
à l'idée de vérité et donc à cette
distinction on ne peut pas croire
quelque chose que l'on tient pour faux 3
on conçoit spontanément la vérité comme
transcendante on ne peut pas décider de
ce qui est vrai ce qui est vrai est vrai
indépendamment de moi cela revient
généralement à comprendre la vérité
selon un principe de fidélité une
proposition vraie est une proposition
qui décrit fidèlement le réel et non pas
donc du principe que le réel est
indépendant du regard que l'on porte sur
lui ce dernier point est critique c'est
un postulation doute intuitif et
largement partagé mais qu'on gagnerait
je crois à remettre en cause ça aussi ça
devrait faire l'objet d'une autre vidéo
bref je crois que la critique formulée
par le scepticisme à l'égard de
l'astrologie articule ces trois
dimensions il est problématique de
croire en astrologie au sens où cela
revient à accorder de la valeur à un
discours parce qu'on voit en lui une
description fidèle d'un mécanisme à
l'oeuvre dans le réel alors que tout
porte à croire que ce discours échoue
précisément à décrire fidèlement la
réalité c'est tout simplement ce qu'on
appelle se tromper
bon pour y voir plus clair on peut donc
distinguer deux objets de croyance il y
a d'une part croire des états de fait
c'est à dire par exemple croire que la
superficie de l'Algérie fait 2 millions
400 000 km2 croire qu'une molécule d'eau
est composée d'un atome d'oxygène et de
deux atomes d'hydrogène croire qu'il dit
kinson est né en 1830 et morte en 1886
ce sont des choses su des choses que
l'on peut aisément vérifier dans le même
sens on peut croire des hypothèses des
interprétations qu'on estime
théoriquement vérifiables même si on n'a
pas les moyens sur le moment de procéder
à une vérification on peut dire que ces
hypothèses ont l'ambition de devenir des
fesses avérées
ainsi même si ce sont des hypothèses
elles appartiennent au même registre de
croyance que celui des états de faits
parce qu'elle participe de cet objectif
de description fidèle du monde et il y a
d'autre part le fait de croire des idées
des valeurs c'est très différent je
crois mettons calice me donne un conseil
elle me dit par exemple que je devrais
quitter mon boulot qu'est-ce que cela
implique de croire Alice il me semble
que cela implique qu'il est vrai qu'il
est dans mon intérêt des démissionner
mais qu'est-ce que cette vérité là
il semble qu'elle soit à jamais un
vérifiable si je démissionne on ne saura
jamais ce corps était ma vie si j'avais
décidé de rester et si je reste on ne
saura jamais ce que serait devenu ma vie
si j'avais démissionné
en un sens elle est virtuellement
vérifiable dans la mesure où on peut
imaginer des mondes parallèles qui
permettraient de faire une comparaison
théorique mais elle est actuellement à
vérifiable parce qu'on ne pourra jamais
conclure avec fumant de certitude on ne
pourra jamais vérifier pour autant même
si on reconnaît qu'il est impossible de
vérifier rigoureusement la véracité de
la parole d'Alice on peut quand même
intuitivement la trouver plus ou moins
crédible on peut y croire ou au
contraire on peut en douter mais
pourquoi peut-on croire ou douter d'une
idée un vérifiable
c'est parce qu'on continue de recevoir
ce type dénoncé sous le prisme de la
distinction vrai faux même si le Conseil
délice est un vérifiable la valeur que
je lui accorde tient à son degré de
proximité à la vérité un petit peu comme
si j'étais au fond incapable d'évaluer
une proposition indépendamment de la
perspective de l'état de fait le Conseil
d'Alice vaut par sa capacité à décrire
correctement la situation on fait comme
si on pouvait comparer les deux mondes
celui où je quitte mon taf et celui où
je reste et on se dit plus ou moins
consciemment le Conseil d'Alice et le
bon si en comparant ces deux monde il
apparaît que je suis plus heureux dans
celui où je quitte mon boulot ce que je
veux dire ici c'est qu'il semble que la
valeur d'une phrase est souvent réduite
à sa capacité avéré ou supposer à
décrire adéquatement ce qui est et ce
qui peut être
et en un sens cela fait tenir la valeur
d'une proposition à sa fidélité à
l'existant en quel sens et bien ce que
je veux dire c'est que la crédibilité
d'un monde possible semble intimement
liée à la continuité qu'il tisse avec le
monde d'aujourd'hui et l'état actuel des
connaissances
autrement dit sa crédibilité dépend de
la quantité de rupture relativement au
monde que l'on connaît que son événement
implique moins il y a des ruptures
nécessaires pour faire advenir ce monde
théorique plus il est crédible et vice
versa si j'imagine différents mondes
possibles je quitte mon taf 1 dans le
premier disons que je me découvre une
nouvelle passion pour la finance et que
je fais fortune à Wall Street dans le
second je suis au chômage et je tombe
dans un état dépressif et 3 je me
consacre à faire des vidéos Youtube je
retrouve des angoisses liées à la
précarité mais je profite de ne plus
subir les contraintes liées aux salariat
si le dernier monde me semble le plus
crédible c'est que c'est lui qui suppose
le moins de 10 continuité avec le monde
actuel il n'applique pas de sérieux
changements dans ma personnalité ou dans
mes compétences par exemple en ce sens
si on fait tenir la valeur d'un conseil
de vie à la crédibilité qu'on associe au
monde possible que le Conseil implique
et si on fait tenir la crédibilité d'un
monde possible à sa proximité avec le
monde que l'on connaît cela semble
conduire à encourager des conseils d'un
certain type en l'occurrence des
conseils mesurés sérieux ancrés sur
l'existant cela suppose donc que
l'intérêt ou la valeur du Conseil
d'Alice dépend un de l'état du monde tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui et de sa proximité
avec ce monde la valeur que j'accorde au
Conseil daliste tient à sa capacité à
dire vrai sur ce que mon monde peut
effectivement devenir et donc de manière
plus générale cela suppose que toute
proposition tournée vers un autre monde
possible toute phrase construite autour
d'un devrait ou pourrait est examiné
depuis l'angle du crédit ou du probable
et je crois que ce n'est pas anodin du
tout
[Musique]
donc une question qui m'intéresse
désormais est la suivante qu'est-ce que
cela pourrait vouloir dire de recevoir
le Conseil d'Alice en dehors de cette
interprétation binaire indépendamment de
sa crédibilité et bien ce pourrait
supposer par exemple de m'interroger sur
ce que j'aime dans mon travail et au
contraire ce qui m'ennuie ce qui me fait
peur ce qui m'excite etc
cela pourrait me faire réfléchir à mes
désirs simplement en observant le genre
de sentiment que la phrase d'Alice
provoque en moi
la phrase alice ne serait plus en ce
sens ni vrai ni fosse elle ne serait pas
jugée en fonction de sa capacité à
décrire plus ou moins fidèlement ce qui
est ou ce qui peut être elle serait plus
ou moins stimulante plus ou moins
enrichissante pour moi qu'il a reçoit
elle serait jugée en fonction de sa
capacité à produire en moi de nouvelles
pensées vous voyez la différence
j'espère que j'arrive à la mettre en
valeur encore une fois cela suppose que
c'est le contexte qui compte la valeur
de la phrase dépend de celui à qui elle
s'adresse à quel moment de son existence
dans quelle situation psychologique etc
je regrette un peu que nos réflexions
soient si souvent définies par cette
dichotomie vraie faux c'est très
limitant pour la pensée de fonctionner
sur ce mode binaire alors je sais bien
que certains adeptes du scepticisme ont
envie de m'opposer la carte base oui ok
si on pense en termes de probabilité
alors nos pensées et nos croyances se
situent sur un spectre et échappe à une
approche résolument manichéenne mais ça
ne change pas grand chose à ce que je
veux dire ici parce que la valeur et la
signification d'une croyance reste
relative à son positionnement sur le
spectre et se positionnement n'est
déterminable que relativement aux deux
extrémités vrai faux
je veux bien qu'on dise que rien n'est
vrai ou faux à 100% et je suis prêt à
accepter que cela change un peu notre
rapport au fait de croire ceci ou cela
mais entre nous ça ne semble pas
bouleversé notre disposition mentale
malgré tout il existe virtuellement sur
ce spectre un point qui correspond à ce
que nous croyons le plus fermement
possible et un point qui correspond à ce
dont nous doutons un maximum ces deux
points jouent un rôle spécifique dans
notre pensée ils mettent un terme à la
croyance il délimite pour le dire
autrement il est naturel et intuitif
d'avoir avec la croyance la moins
crédible la même relation que celle que
l'on aurait avec une proposition que
l'on jugerait absolument fausse
je veux dire que nous percevons
spontanément le plus probable comme
absolument vrai et le moins probable
comme absolument faux
même si on distingue consciemment
l'extrêmement probable de l'absolument
vrai même si l'on considère que rien
n'est absolument vrai ou absolument faux
on le ressent comme si c'était
absolument vrai ou absolument faux
si je fais une introspection je suis
obligé de reconnaître que la proposition
il y a des licornes au sommet de la Tour
Eiffel m’apparaît dans mon esprit comme
absolument fausse je ne la ressens pas
comme extrêmement peu probable mais
comme fausse tout simplement
et si je suis honnête je dois mettre que
tout un tas de propositions me font
exactement les mêmes effets quand bien
même elles sont moins improbables que
celle-ci la proposition dans deux ans le
fascisme aura disparu de la planète me
fait le même effet mental que la
proposition il y a une licorne au sommet
de la Tour Eiffel mon inconscient les
range dans la même case je traite ses
croyances exactement comme si j'étais
absolument fausse je ne leur donne
aucune place aucune fonction dans ma vie
mentale que je refuserai à des croyances
absolument fausses si on parle en termes
phénoménologique je veux dire sinon se
concentre sur la manière dont ces
croyances se manifestent spontanément
dans ma conscience il est impossible de
les distinguer et cela révèle je crois
en un sens une approche de la croyance
plutôt binaire revenons brièvement à la
position représentation versus
dispositionnalisme
dans le premier cas la croyance renvoie
à une conception mentale consciente
ainsi je crois expérimenter deux types
de croyances selon que je me rapporte à
la proposition il y a des licornes en
haut de la tour Eiffel ou à la
proposition le fascisme aura disparu en
2024 parce que quand j'y pense
consciemment je reconnais une différence
entre ces deux propositions et si au
contraire on adopte le dispositionnisme
selon lequel les croyances renvoient
d'abord et avant tout un comportement
alors on voit bien que ces deux
propositions renvoient à un même type de
croyance puisque mon comportement ne
diffère pas entre les deux il n'y a donc
de ce point de vue que deux familles de
comportements possibles soit j'agis
comme si x est vrai ou faux soit j'agis
en fonction de mon degré de certitude de
l'incertitude relatif à X bref tout ça
pour reconnaître qu'il y a malgré toute
notre bonne volonté et notre sérieux des
choses auxquelles on va se rapporter
comme si elles étaient absolument vrai
et des choses auxquelles on va se
rapporter comme s'ils étaient absolument
fausses
et dans la continuité de ce constat il
semble que l'on rabat toute croyance sur
la dimension factuelle c'est-à-dire
descriptive Alice me dit que je devrais
changer de métier et mon esprit
spontanément interroge la valeur de la
proposition d'Alice en terme factuel
serais-je effectivement plus heureux si
je change de métier ou comme on le
disait en termes descriptif le monde que
décrit implicitement la proposition
d'Alice est-il réellement davantage
plaisant que celui dans lequel je vis
présentement ce sont comme vous voyez
des questions fermées on est censé y
répondre par oui ou non d'où le
caractère réducteur et binaire que je
regrette
[Musique]
je suis donc tenté de proposer une autre
attitude une autre manière de recevoir
le Conseil d'Alice on pourrait commencer
par distinguer d'un côté les paroles
d'arrivée et de l'autre les paroles de
départ
une parole d'arrivée c'est une parole
qui conclut qui présente un état de fait
sa valeur est informée c'est ce qui
correspond à l'approche descriptive on
décrit ce qui est ou ce qui serait
situé-t-elle circonstances venait à
changer au contraire une parole de
départ c'est une parole qui ouvre sur
une autre manière de voir les choses qui
interroge sa valeur est de donner à
penser ça ne consiste pas à décrire ce
qui est ou ce qui serait ni même ce qui
pourrait être cela consiste à perturber
nos habitudes intellectuelles à ébranler
notre manière d'expérimenter le monde
je peux prendre la proposition d'Alice
comme une parole d'arrivée et donc m'ont
demandé si oui ou non je serai plus
heureux en changeant de métier ou comme
on disait je peux la prendre comme une
parole de départ et me demander ce que
la remarque m'inspire les projections
mentales qu'elle fait advenir en moi les
pressentiments les craintes les
aspirations rien n'empêche d'ailleurs de
combiner les deux ainsi je peux voir le
Conseil d'Alice à la fois comme une
parole de départ qui interroge mes choix
mes valeurs et comme une parole
d'arrivée qui me révèle un état de fait
ce qu'elle perçoit de ma personne et qui
peut être m'échappe par exemple que mes
amis me perçoivent comme malheureux au
travail
par ailleurs il faut remarquer une autre
dimension de cette opposition dans le
cas d'un conseil comme celui d'Alice la
valeur d'une parole d'arrivée tient au
crédit accordé à celui ou celle qui
l'énonce je peux faire plus ou moins
confiance à la perspicacité d'Alice par
exemple faire confiance à l'hypothèse
c'est faire confiance au regard qui est
à son origine
au contraire la valeur d'une parole de
départ tient la richesse des idées que
l'on en tire à ce qu'on lui fait dire
voire même à ce qu'on lui fait faire car
la puissance d'une parole de départ est
précisément d'impulsée dans notre esprit
toute une série d'actions évalué
imaginez projeter pressentir en un sens
ce sont des responsabilités totalement
opposées dans le premier cas c'est Alice
qui est responsable de la pertinence de
son hypothèse elle me propose une
manière d'interpréter ma vie et la
validité de cette interprétation est
fondée sur sa perspicacité sa justesse
d'analyses sa finesse psychologique etc
dans le second cas pour la parole de
départ c'est moi qui fut responsable de
l'intérêt porté à la proposition ce qui
compte ce n'est pas de savoir si
l'hypothèse d'Alice décrit un monde
probable ou crédible ce qui compte ce
sont les images et idées que mon esprit
génère à la rencontre de l'hypothèse
tout l'intérêt de ce que dit Alice tient
à ma capacité à en faire quelque chose
de stimulant quelque chose qui me libère
de ma façon habituelle de voir les
choses et donc si on en revient au
problème de l'astrologie ou du tarot
c'est un peu pareil mettons qu'on me
fait tirer le tarot je pose la question
dois-je changer de métier je tire les
cartes et leurs symbolique est censé
m'aider à répondre à la question
je tire les cartes et parce qu'elles
disent toutes quelque chose parce que le
jeu de tarot est un objet culturel plein
de symbolique et de signification on
peut dire qu'un tirage de cartes tient
une forme de discours c'est une parole
disons que je tire la carte de la lune
et on me donne sa signification c'est le
moment d'akalmie propice à la bonne
décision la lune rappelle qu'il est
temps d'opérer une transition
si je prends ça comme une parole
d'arrivée alors rappelez-vous cela
suppose que la responsabilité est dans
les cartes elle-même c'est à dire que la
valeur qu'on attribue au discours que
tient ses cartes relativement à ma
question est fondée sur le tirage ou sur
la personne qui m'a fait tirer et c'est
là qu'intervient quelque chose comme de
la superstition pour que des cartes
tirées au hasard puissent dire quelque
chose de pertinent il faut faire
intervenir une forme de magie il faut
sous-entendre qu'elle ne furent pas
tirées totalement au hasard c'est à dire
par exemple quelque chose comme je crois
qu'il faut que je change de métier parce
que les cartes tirées laissent entendre
que j'avais grandement besoin de changer
mon quotidien sous-entendu parce que je
crois que par un procédé mystérieux les
cartes que l'on tire disait qu'elles
savent effectivement ce dont j'ai besoin
la valeur d'un tirage de cartes tient
alors entièrement à l'espèce de magie
qui doit opérer si les cartes sont
vraiment tirées au hasard alors le
discours ne peut avoir aucune valeur
descriptive mais du point de vue de la
parole de départ c'est tout à fait
différent je peux bien reconnaître que
les cartes sont irrés au hasard ça ne
m'empêche pas d'interroger ce qu'elle
dise je peux me voir réagir au discours
qu'elle propose je peux découvrir que
j'ai peur de changer de métier c'est une
carte ni invite je peux réfléchir à ce
qui constitue une accalmie dans ma vie
et interroger les décisions que je
prends au milieu des tempêtes bref vous
voyez l'idée je peux recevoir ça comme
une proposition qui ne met pas
personnellement adressé mais qui
m'oblige à me poser certaines questions
qui me poussent à réfléchir qui m'invite
à me projeter après sentir à visualiser
et je crois qu'il est difficile de nier
que cela a de la valeur cela donne à
penser cela fait réfléchir différemment
cela contraint l'esprit à interpréter à
partir d'un donné qui n'est pas habituel
à partir d'un discours différent avec
des symboles des archétypes cela me fait
penser en dehors de mon cadre habituel
de réflexion
la dichotomie parole d'arrivée et parle
de départ invite aussi à questionner
l'autorité d'une parole et là on revient
à ce que je disais au tout début de la
vidéo quand je reconnaissais la
potentielle toxicité des discours
astrologiques ou des tirages de cartes
etc
ce qui est problématique ce n'est pas
tant que la phrase soit factuellement
fausse ce qui est problématique c'est
que précisément on confère une autorité
à ses discours le problème c'est donc
l'autorité elle-même c'est parce qu'un
discours prétend dire vrai qu'il devient
un devoir qui s'impose à nous une phrase
qui prétend dire vrai c'est une phrase
qui affirme que nous devons reconnaître
que le monde est bel et bien tel qu'il
est décrit par la phrase c'est une forme
d'ordre cela dit votre expérience de
l'existence doit se modeler sur cette
description vous devez voir les choses
ainsi c'est ça la parole d'arrivée et
c'est pas rien ça quand même quand on me
dit comme ça une affirmation à laquelle
on reconnaît une autorité va venir
modeler et définir notre expérience de
l'existence d'où l'intérêt d'apprendre à
nourrir avec les paroles et les discours
un rapport différent un rapport où on
n'est pas immédiatement exposé à une
modélisation autoritaire du réel
un rapport où on peut en un sens
librement pensé
un espace mental où l'on peut réfléchir
imaginer inventer des concepts des idées
des perspectives sans avoir à répondre à
toute une série de critères qui
s'imposent quand on prétend dire la
vérité
le problème pour revenir à notre point
de départ c'est donc d'enfermer notre
relation à l'astrologie ou à toute autre
pratique du même genre dans cette
conception binaire soit j'y crois soit
je n'y crois pas au contraire une
relation rationnelle et un tel discours
doit émerger hors d'une telle dichotomie
il ne s'agit ni d'y croire ni de ne pas
y croire il s'agit d'en faire un
tremplin pour penser vous imaginez ce
que ça change pour les textes religieux
si l'on part du principe qu'ils viennent
de Dieu et si on a une conception un peu
naïve de Dieu je veux dire un dieu
personnifié qui a des intentions et des
pensées comme un humain alors le texte
et l'autorité ultime il doit donc
impérativement être compris c'est-à-dire
déchiffrer décrypter ce qui est une
relation à un texte somme toute assez
banal et peut-être même un peu
réductrice
en un sens le texte religieux et la
parole d'arrivée par excellence et elle
porte une vérité supposément définitive
et absolue mais si au contraire on
aborde ces textes avec l'état d'esprit
propre à la parole de départ avec une
attitude qui me semble d'ailleurs
compatible avec d'autres conceptions du
divin si on y cherche des images des
sensations des pressentiments des
réactions il est possible sans même
adhérer à la fois en question en tirer
une expérience très riche
[Musique]
au fond sans doute peut-on faire un
parallèle avec la fiction vous lisez un
livre vous regardez un film une série
même si ce qui racontait ne renvoie en
rien à l'effet établi vous pouvez quand
même en tirer une expérience
intéressante la fiction peut transformer
notre façon de voir le monde de le
comprendre elle peut faire bouger nos
critères nos préjugés ce n'est pas sans
valeur quand on expérimente de la
fiction on entre plus volontiers dans
l'état d'esprit parole de départ
vous souvenez-vous de cette intervention
de Ricky Gervais
to everyton
je ferai bientôt une vidéo sur les
croyances religieuses et je m'attendrai
davantage dessus à ce moment-là mais je
voudrais quand même relever quelque
chose dès maintenant ce discours est une
belle illustration de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler pompeusement la réduction
adfactum si l'humanité reportée de zéro
elle produirait la même séance dit-il
bon déjà on peut sérieusement en douter
mais ce n'est même pas le sujet ici
semble affirmer que seuls qui est
factuel et digne d'être valorisé ce qui
repose sans doute sur une conception
assez simpliste d'ailleurs de ce qui
constitue un fait mais à la limite peu
importe si l'humanité repartait de zéro
elle ne produirait sans doute pas à
l'identique les mêmes films les mêmes
livres les mêmes chansons or la valeur
que ces productions ont dans nos vies ne
tient pas à leur capacité à décrire des
états de fait au contraire elles
inventent proposent imaginent envisage
soulignent
pour le dire autrement ce n'est pas
parce qu'une chose ne prétend pas
d'écrire la réalité qu'elle est dénuée
de toute valeur ce n'est pas parce que
les cartes sont tirées au hasard ce
n'est pas parce que mon destin n'est pas
effectivement lié aux planètes qu'un
tirage ou un thème ne peut provoquer en
moi des réflexions fines et pertinentes
le problème c'est donc notre tendance à
tout recevoir comme parole d'arrivée
c'est un mauvais réflexe cela fait
dépendre la valeur d'une proposition
d'une phrase d'une idée de l'existant et
du possible c'est-à-dire que cela réduit
la valeur de la pensée à ce qui est et à
ce qui peut être à l'intérieur du monde
tel qu'on le connaît déjà c'est une
forme de défense du statu quo c'est ne
donner de la valeur qu'est-ce qui existe
et ce qui peut exister or ce qui peut
exister dépend étroitement de ce qui
existe ce qui peut être venir est par
définition une continuation de ce qui
est déjà
puisque ce qui advient est causé par ce
qui est déjà
de sorte qu'on s'empêche toute rupture
toute pensée capable de faire rupture
capable de provoquer une réelle
différence dans notre regard
bien sûr nous avons besoin de paroles
d'arrivée il ne s'agit pas ici de la
refuser tout intérêt mais je crois qu'on
gagnerait à faire un peu plus de place
aux paroles de départ
je disais au début de la vidéo que nos
critiques de l'astrologie étaient
révélatrice et qu'elle mettait en
lumière un danger pour la pensée et bien
voilà elle révèle notre propension à
évaluer toute proposition en termes de
crédibilité relative à ce qui est déjà
connu et le danger c'est donc qu'en
cultivant cette tendance nous limitons
notre capacité à produire des idées
différentes de celles qui domine notre
expérience nous limitons la plasticité
de notre regard sur le monde au
contraire nous prenons le risque de nous
enfermer dans nos habitudes de penser
nous ne valorisons plus que le connu il
connaissable nous ne coupons de
l'inimaginable et cela pose plus
largement la question de la place et de
la valeur que l'on accorde au discours
dans l'intérêt ne repose pas sur la
description dans l'intérêt ne tient pas
à la fidélité de la description
donc quid de la fiction faut-il la
réduire à du plaisir tel pas plus qu'une
friandise pour l'esprit et si nous
faisons de la fiction à un moyen
détourner d'apprendre sur nous-mêmes ou
sur le monde n'est-ce pas au fond une
manière de la rabattre sur cette idéale
descriptif la fiction ne pourrait-elle
être une ouverture sur une autre réalité
suivant d'autres règles d'autres
systèmes de valeurs et quid de la
philosophie je veux dire de la
philosophie qui ne prétend pas
participer à la grande quête
scientifique de description du réel la
philosophie qui crée des concepts qui
fabriquent une langue qui transforment
nos affects pourquoi fait-on si peu de
place à ce discours qui cherchent moins
à décrire la vie qu'elle a changé et
enfin quid de la religion de la
théologie quel rapport pouvons-nous
tisser à ses discours si nous nous
libérons de cette dichotomie quelle
ampleur le concept de Dieu peut-il
prendre si on ne se bande pas à se
demander s'il faut y croire ou non
quel sera une relation au concept de
Dieu libérée de la problématique de la
croyance voilà une question vertigineuse
bref voici mon hypothèse je crois que la
vérité comme idéale la vérité comme
horizon vers lequel nous faisons tendre
notre pensée suppose qu'il existe
quelque chose qui puisse valider notre
repentation du monde et cette chose
c'est sans doute qu'on appelle réalité
or le déconstruisons pas suffisamment le
concept de réalité nous le prenons pour
acquis la réalité pense-t-on c'est ce
qui me précède et me succède ce qui
existe sans moi à cet égard la réalité
et la grande autorité transcendante
c'est ce qu'on ne saurait remettre en
cause c'est ce à quoi nous devons nous
soumettre nous plier un peu comme Dieu
du coup
quand bien même on consolerait que nos
représentations mentales du monde ne
pourront jamais atteindre la réalité
quand bien même on ne ferait qu'un idéal
régulateur elle représenterait malgré
tout un critère absolu à l'aune duquel
on va juger les propositions
nous croyons alors qu'il existe une
instance certes un personnel et des
lieux d'intention à partir de laquelle
nous pouvons évoluer nos pensées et
croyances plus elle semble conforme à la
réalité plus elles ont de valeur
tant que notre pensée est enfermée dans
la binarité y croire ou ne pas y croire
nous restons esclaves du fantasme de la
transcendance ainsi voyons-nous par
exemple l'ivresse ou les expériences
associées au psychotropes comme des
états confus des égarements passagers on
parle d'ailleurs des termes modifié de
conscience comme si on partait du
principe que la conscience quotidienne
était l'état normale c'est-à-dire l'état
le plus fidèle à la réalité
nous nous empêchons d'expérimenter nous
appauvrissons notre relation à
l'existence parce que nous avons peur de
l'erreur de la tromperie du mensonge
parce que nous n'avons pas appris à
vivre par de là la distinction vraie
faux parce que nous avons un désir quasi
insociable de vérité de réalité et
peut-être parce que la réalité la vérité
c'est l'autorité et c'est donc le
pouvoir comme il est rassurant de penser
qu'on dit vrai
[Musique]
on n'échappa la question que faut-il
croire et cette question est assez
rigolote si on la décortique d'un côté
on a à croire qui renvoie intuitivement
à la connaissance et à la vérité soit ce
qu'on croit est vrai soit c'est faux on
ne pense pas spontanément autre chose
quand il est question de croyance de
l'autre côté on a falloir qui renvoie
directement à l'idée de devoir et donc à
la morale elle fait écho à la question
que faut-il faire qui a d'évidence
implications éthiques et donc la
question que faut-il croire je crois
qu'elle est héritière de la Sainte
Trinité qu'on trouve déjà chez Platon et
qui articule le beau le bien le vrai que
faut-il croire le vrai car le vrai est
forcément bon voilà ce qui s'impose à
notre intuition mais on gagnerait à
interroger ce présupposé car au fond
rien ne nous empêche de libérer nos
croyances de cette conception disons
réaliste de la vérité ce qu'il faut
croire ou ce qu'il convient de croire ou
ce qu'on a intérêt de croire c'est une
question morale politique et également
une question existentielle
d'être une question épistémique avant
d'être une affaire de connaissance et
tout ça simplement à cause du verbe
falloir au fond
on peut facilement expliquer l'intuition
sur laquelle il faut croire le vrai et
ce qu'il faudrait c'est de voir ce
serait tout simplement l'idéal
d'harmonie sociale ce serait là que
reposerait la valeur politique de la
vérité le vrai c'est ce qui m'est
d'accord c'est ce qui oblige la semaine
d'accord la vérité est une sanction
quand deux individus voient les choses
différemment ils peuvent être contraints
de se plier à l'autorité qu'incarne le
vrai lors des Accords est écrasé par la
vérité sa règle les conflits
que le considère la vérité comme une
transcendance ou comme une construction
sociale et culturelle elle joue
inévitablement d'une forme d'autorité
bon ce qui est vraiment terrible avec ce
genre de vidéo c'est qu'il y a des
embranchements possibles voire
nécessaire toutes les 30 secondes là
j'aimerais ajouter une parenthèse de 20
minutes autour de cette tension
vertigineuse qui affleure quand on
évoque l'horizon d'une harmonie sociale
vous le savez déjà sans doute je n'ai
pas spécialement envie de protéger le
statut quo aussi n'ai-je pas du tout
envie de stigmatiser les comportements
qu'on qualifie parfois de marginaux et
plus généralement les comportements
susceptibles de déstabiliser
l'organisation sociale au contraire même
j'ai plutôt l'impression que l'ordre
établit et non seulement injuste mais
trop autoritaire et quand je dis
autoritaire cela renvoie donc aussi bien
au comportement que croyances la société
est un espace normé et contraignant
certes
critiquer cette dimension autoritaire et
contraignante cela ne suppose pas de
nier l'existence de comportement
toxiques des comportements que l'on veut
donc légitimement voir disparaître et
bien sûr que nos comportements sont
étroitement liés à nos croyances donc à
la question que faut-il croire je
comprends bien qu'on peut avoir envie de
répondre il faut adopter des croyances
qui ne génèrent pas de comportement
toxiques il faut éviter ce qui fait
souffrir autrui tout simplement
intuitivement c'est ce que je soupçonne
derrière l'idéal d'harmonie sociale un
monde où on fait le maximum pour que les
gens souffrent le minimum et comme on
disait il y a une espèce d'association
spontanée qui suppose que la vérité est
forcément belle et bonne
cela nous invite à déduire que la vérité
va nous rapprocher de cet idéal
d'harmonie sociale que si tout le monde
connaissait la vérité le monde irait
forcément mieux voir il serait aussi bon
que possible
sans doute qu'il y a là quelque chose
qu'on peut identifier historiquement le
culte du progrès progrès technique ou
progrès de la raison est un mythe qu'il
est temps d'associer à cette confusion
vraie bien que faut-il croire le vrai
parce que du vrai ne peut rien décoller
de mauvais mais comme on questionne pas
fondamentalement rigoureusement
profondément ce qu'on appelle vrai ça
devient sans surprise les meilleures
croyances que l'on peut adopter sont
celles qui sont fondées sur une
description fidèle de la réalité
alors qu'on pourrait dire par exemple
les meilleures croyances sont celles qui
transforment notre rapport au monde dans
le sens que l'on souhaite c'est une
position pragmatiste mais là encore il
faudrait une vidéo à part là dessus
la première chose que je veux partager
avec vous c'est l'intérêt de distinguer
la valeur épistémique des croyances de
leur valeur morale en gros c'est pas
parce qu'une croyance est solide sur le
plan épistémique qu'elle en devient
automatiquement légitime du point de vue
moral et par conséquent ce n'est pas
parce que notre croyance n'est pas
robuste sur le plan épistémique que
c'est une croyance moralement
problématique donc la quête de vérité
n'est pas un impératif moral c'est un
choix existentiel
en réalité une fois la valeur morale de
la croyance assurée on peut croire ce
qu'on veut si d'un côté on fait tout ce
qu'on veut pour participer à rendre la
société la plus juste possible on peut
tous permettre on peut chercher à
adopter les croyances les plus
enrichissantes
la question qui m'intéresse est donc
plutôt que peut-on croire et ici pouvoir
renvoie bien à une capacité qu'est-ce
que je suis capable de croire quelle
relation à l'expérience suis-je capable
de tisser et poser les choses ainsi ça
me fait penser à la drogue et plus
particulièrement à l'image social des
usagers de drogue parce qu'il y en a de
forts enjeux politiques et
philosophiques notamment autour des
questions de normes et de marginalité
autour des questions de santé de
puissance de valeur et de signification
de l'expérience
je prépare depuis longtemps inscrite sur
la question parce que c'est un sujet qui
compte énormément pour moi
donc sans entrer dans le détail je
voudrais juste dire qu'il y a une sorte
de méfiance de la part de l'opinion
publique à l'égard des usagers de drogue
précisément parce qu'ils sont refusés la
réalité de tout le monde en un sens
parce qu'il crée leur propre réalité
comme si la société leur en voulait de
s'échapper dans un autre monde de
produire un autre système de valeurs que
celui contente de leur imposer et je
crois que si les usagers de drogue ont
mauvaise réputation dans la société si
leur mode de vie est stigmatisé c'est
précisément à cause de cette obsession
pour la vérité en tant que norme
je ne parle pas d'une quête
obsessionnelle pour la vérité mais bien
de ce besoin d'autorité que traduit le
besoin de vérité c'est une espèce de
triangulaire conceptuel d'abord elle est
une transcendance pour que la vérité de
la valeur il faut qu'elle me dépasse il
ne peut pas être de mon ressort de
décider ce qui est vrai ou faux donc
logiquement elle renvoie l'idée de
réalité ce qui crée une espèce
d'équivalence dans notre esprit la
réalité comme la vérité c'est ce qui ne
dépend pas de moi et en un sens c'est
même ceux qui s'oppose à moi ce qui me
contraint ce qui m'oblige donc c'est
aussi une norme c'est ce qui va orienter
mon comportement et donc mon expérience
la norme renvoie inévitablement au
devoir parce que c'est le comportement
socialement accepté celui qu'on nous
encourage à adopter c'est le
comportement valorisé c'est ce qu'il
convient de faire
d'où l'idée qu'il faut croire ce qui
décrit adéquatement la réalité d'où
l'idée qu'une croyance valide sur le
plan épidémique et forcément aussi
moralement valide les trois pointes du
triangle se renforcent mutuellement ça
devient très difficile de s'en libérer
et donc pour en revenir à la drogue le
sentiment qui nous fait penser que
l'expérience vécue par l'entremise d'un
psychotrope n'est pas vraiment la
réalité et intimement lié au triangle
dans l'imaginaire collectif c'est même
l'envers de ce triangle commençons par
l'aspect transcendant de la vérité et
bien on reprend à l'expérience avec
psychotrope d'être un genre de bulle de
rêve de n'exister que dans la tête de
celui ou celle qui la vie ça ne vaudrait
rien parce que ça ne vaudrait pour
personne d'autre en gros
dans le même genre d'autres idées sans
surprise l'expérience est qualifiée
d'illusoir on se moquera plus ou moins
gentiment des prises de conscience ou
des épiphanies vécu à l'aide d'une
drogue parce que cette expérience est
différente de celle qu'on a l'habitude
de faire au quotidien alors elle serait
forcément
erronée c'est l'idée que notre cerveau
fonctionne bien en temps normal et qu'il
fonctionne de travers quand on prend une
substance enfin le fait de valoriser de
telles expériences renvoie à un
comportement qu'on stigmatise
injustement à mon sens comme déviant ces
expériences sont tout simplement
différentes de celles que vivent la
plupart des gens et en cela elles
paraissent aux yeux de la société
incompatible avec les exigences d'une
vie sociale harmonieuse
je fais ce petit détour par l'usage des
drogues simplement pour mettre en
lumière la pression sociale à adopter
certains comportements et certaines
croyances cette idée selon laquelle il
faut croire ce qui est réel il faut
vivre dans la réalité et ici réel
renvoie à une conception super étroite
autoritaire énormément de la réalité or
je le répète je crois qu'on a intérêt à
déconstruire cette attitude
imaginons que Alice a des croyances
super étranges elle est persuadée d'être
dans le rêve de quelqu'un c'est même pas
elle qui rêve c'est toute son existence
qui est le produit du rêve d'une
personne c'est quand même sacrément
différent de ce que nous croyons tous
pour Alice ce qu'un homme réalité n'a
pas du tout le même sens
émettons que cette croyance réalise
particulièrement heureuse être un rêve
lui donne l'impression que chacune de
ces expériences est incroyablement
précieuse parallèlement si Alice est
tout de même respectueux des individus
qu'elle croise dans sa réalité rêve si
elle s'investit dans la société si elle
adhère à une morale si elle a de la
compassion pourquoi devrait-elle
abandonner sa croyance
sa réalité est peut-être incompatible
avec la nôtre sur le plan épistémique
mais elle ne l'est pas sur le plan moral
et politique la question de savoir ce
qu'il convient de croire n'est pas une
question épistémologique c'est une
question philosophique nous n'avons
aucune légitimité de demander à Alice
d'abandonner sa croyance nous ne sommes
concernés que par les comportements des
gens pas parce qu'ils croient et pense
je ne nie pas que les croyances et les
comportements sont liés je dis qu'il est
malhonnête de partir du principe que les
croyances farfelues impliquent
nécessairement un comportement néfaste
ou toxique pour les autres et donc c'est
une manière de dire que la valeur
épistémique d'une croyance n'est pas la
seule qui compte il y a la valeur morale
celle qui tient au comportement causé
par la croyance et il y a la valeur
existentielle celle qui renvoie à la
richesse de l'expérience richesse
sensible perceptive émotionnelle
intellectuelle etc
certaines croyances donnent plus à vivre
plus à sentir plus à penser que d'autres
il faut distinguer ces trois aspects de
la croyance reprenons Alice et observant
sa croyance sous le prisme de ces trois
valeurs et regardons Bob un chirurgien
athé qui se qualifie de rationalistes
sceptiques à valeur morale égale quelle
croyance choisissez-vous et pourquoi la
valeur existentielle c'est un peu ce qui
est en jeu dans une certaine philosophie
et une certaine littérature
je regrette qu'on met pas l'accent sur
la capacité de ces textes à transformer
notre expérience de la vie
je regrette qu'au lycée ou à
l'université on en fait des objets
d'études plutôt que des objets
d'expérience je regrette qu'on en fasse
un élément de distinction sociale plutôt
qu'un outil pour explorer l'existence
nos croyances forment le tissu de nos
expériences elles ont défini la couleur
la profondeur l'intensité il est
possible de construire des croyances qui
enrichissent terriblement l'existence
mais on ne semble obsédé que par la
connaissance que par la valeur
épistémique que par l'autorité que la
vérité confère à côté de quelle vie
possible passons-nous à quel point notre
expérience de la vie pourrait-elle être
plus profonde
[Musique]
je voudrais préciser quelque chose qui
me semble important j'ai souhaité ici
valoriser une autre forme de relation à
l'esprit que l'on cesse de juger nos
pensées uniquement à l'aune du prisme
épistémique que l'on cesse de moquer
voire mépriser celles et ceux qui
entretiennent un rapport fort à des
propositions peu crédibles il y a autre
chose que la crédibilité dans la vie
mais pour ce faire je me rends compte en
finition de montage j'ai tout de même
joué un jeu qui ne me plaît pas beaucoup
celui de la puissance quantitative
j'ai affirmé que des propositions à
faible valeur épistémique pouvait même
donner davantage à penser j'aurais sans
doute dû dire donner mieux à penser car
il est possible et je crois d'ailleurs
que c'est plus souvent le cas que ce que
l'on veut bien lui faire croire que
mieux penser se rapproche de moins
penser c'est quelque chose que j'aurais
voulu aborder dans cette vidéo
maintenant que j'y pense mais déjà bien
trop longue je crains être tombé dans
lesquelles d'une forme de culte de la
performance intellectuelle au fond ce
qui est sans doute une espèce de
validisme
c'est également ce qui manque à mon
discours sur la fiction je dis qu'elle
nous permet d'imaginer de projeter
l'inventer mais c'est là encore un angle
très actif un idéal productiviste du
rapport à l'esprit la fiction rend aussi
possible une relation contemplative au
monde une expérience plus tranquille
libérée de l'espèce de Fredy mentale qui
accompagne presque nécessairement le
désir de comprendre de réfléchir etc je
ne vois pas de bonnes raisons de
dévaloriser ce type de relation à
l'existence
déconstruire le devoir de croire le vrai
c'est peut-être aussi au fond des
construire le devoir de pensée
déconstruire la valeur intelligence et
l'imaginaire contraignant qui est
associé
en somme il s'agit de déconstruire plus
généralement l'idée qu'il faut réussir
sa vie et qui parvenir suppose presque
automatiquement d'être une personne
performante c'est à dire plus
intelligente plus imaginative plus
original plus solide plus travailleuse
que la moyenne etc
c'est presque tout bêtement le principe
d'évolution qu'il faut remettre en cause
l'idée comme élément admise que l'être
humain doit évoluer et progresser
je suis sûr qu'en disant cela certains
vont y voir le signe de la décadence
fociste les mêmes qui considèrent que le
monde n'a jamais été aussi pu injuste
celles et ceux qui voient la réalité
comme une somme de fait et le
conséquence plutôt qu'en termes de forme
ne faut-il pas rappeler que l'impératif
de performance d'évolution de progrès
impose une forme à l'existence une
faut-il pas interroger quel autre forme
elle pourrait prendre si nous
choisissions un autre idéal au hasard le
soin n'est-il pas là un horizon
intéressant à Visé
il y a peut-être une première pierre à
poser pour construire un tel objectif
c'est justement celui d'observer avec un
peu de recul c'est idéal d'intelligence
ou de performance existentielle or cette
vidéo si elle s'attache à mettre en
perspective la forme spécifique que
revêt aujourd'hui cet idéal si elle
tente maladroitement sans doute d'en
montrer des limites je dois reconnaître
qu'elle manque le coup d'après celui qui
aurait justement constitué en
questionner le principe fondamental une
prochaine fois peut-être
[Musique]